INTO COVERAGE.
THEY ARE
WHAT A SHIFT THEY HAD WHEN THEY
SCORED T
ATTACKING THE NET.
>> CHRIS: THE FOR
THEM.
A BEAUTIFUL LITTLE SAUCERLOOKIN
NOW ANOTHER PLAY, AND FILIP
THIS SHOT.
OVER IN THE CORNER.
HE ATTACKS.:PRESSURE ALLOWS THE
OTHERS TO ATTACK.
>> WILLY: ANOTHE HAVE BEEN
DEFENDING MORE THAN THEY
YOU HAVE TO PAY THE PRICE TO GO
TO THE BLUE PAINDE IN FRONT.
WHAT A SAVE.
REALLY HELPED THIS POWER-
PLAY.
INTO TRAFFIC.
THAT IS RIGHT UNDER THE BAR.
THIS IS A PERFECT SH
YOU CANNOT SEE THE NUMBER.
SCORE.
HE GETS HERE.
WATCH.
HE HAS TO GO UP.
NOVAK FILIP FORSBERG.
4 GOALS.
RECEIVED IT AND DISHES IT OVER
TO COUSINS.
THIS
TO THE NET FRONT. ON THE
NASHVILLE POWE
LET'S NOT FORGET THE SECTION OF
THE GAME IN THE SECOND PERIOD.
COLUMBUS  MADE A PUSH TO GET